so if you follow this channel you know
that we've been reviewing workplace
sensitivity training courses um the kind
that a lot of hr departments force their
employees to watch
mine doesn't but i've taken on this
project anyway by choice because of my
deep-seated masochism and self-hatred
the company that makes these videos is
called m train
they work with a lot of major companies
to help indoctrinate i mean educate
educate people and how to avoid
harassing assaulting
uh or being racist or towards their
co-workers a lot of times
we'll watch a bunch of videos but this
time i want to focus on just one
because this i believe is the worst one
yet the absolute worst
it's it's it's the worst because of the
real world consequences of
if not this specific video the sort of
thing
the video represents so you'll see what
i mean we'll get into this now this is
this is titled
examples of severe and pervasive
workplace harassment
so let's uh let's check this out
so will i see you at that three o'clock
yeah i'll be there
oh you got um got it
i haven't had sex in a month well
excuse me
what school did you go to arizona state
i didn't know they had hot girls at asu
you see lisa's dress today hell yeah man
what's that thing spray painted on
i want a spray paint
they promoted her i know five guys more
qualified than that only five
ah okay so that's what they mean
so let's go through these um i i took
notes i wrote this down
not really but this is severe and
pervasive harassment severe
and pervasive and the examples are we
start with somebody pick some lint off
of her shirt
okay now that one a little inappropriate
you know he didn't appear to touch her
breasts but but
too close for comfort for her perhaps a
little bit iffy
harassment though i don't think so
severe
come on and the other thing is a common
thread we see in all these incidents the
person who's the victim
doesn't speak up for themselves like if
you're uncomfortable with somebody
touching you say something speak up for
yourself
then she briefly hears a guy say the
word sex to another guy
as they're coming off an elevator
harassment no it's not even directed to
her
severe what what is this victorian
england
see this shows how our culture has has
at once become hedonistic and way too
open about sex
at the same time you think about songs
like like [ __ ] for example okay
we have songs like that but then at the
same time we're like downright
puritanical so you
you touch a woman's sweater or say a
word around her and you're essentially
guilty of sexual assault
but then wap is a popular song it's the
strangest dynamic
you can make a song graphically
describing various intimate areas of the
body
at various states of arousal and that's
fine you put that one on it at
applebee's while while the family's
eating dinner at 5 p.m
no problem
[Music]
but a woman literally hears a guy say
sex and she's been
assaulted next a guy calls her hot
okay again shouldn't be saying that at
work not professional harassment
it's it's a compliment severe severe
what severe complimenting
she's a victim of severe complimenting
and then a few days later she overhears
two guys in a stairwell
talking about somebody else's outfit
saying that some other woman
is wearing a tight dress once again
inappropriate for the workplace short
harassment
of her it wasn't directed at her nor was
it about her
either way she was literally on a
different floor of the building
hearing it said about somebody else and
she's being harassed
i mean get over yourself darling not
everyone's focused on you
the next again she overhears i mean this
girl cannot stop
eavesdropping she's just constantly
listening looking at people
what's on people's screens she overhears
two guys talking about presumably some
other woman who they think
shouldn't have been promoted so what
nothing sexual about that
nothing gender specific it's not about
her not directed to her
then after that you have two dudes uh
looking over
towards her when she bends down that
another guy is looking in her direction
you know again iffy i mean that could go
either way and i guess we're supposed to
assume he was looking at her breasts and
then
she sees the wallpaper on somebody's
laptop
and there are pictures of scantily clad
women who are mostly covered up
it looks like they're wearing bathing
suits and then somebody taps her on the
hip so they can get past her
so that's it that's all we got there are
maybe
maybe okay two or three
actually inappropriate behaviors
documented in the video
none of them are severe or close to
severe
if a guy saying sex is severe harassment
then what what word do we use to
describe actual harassment
because if non-harassment is severe
then what do we say about real
harassment when it actually happens
i guess non-harassment is severe
harassment so real harassment is now
like what fatal it's fatal harassment
the consequence again is that women you
know they take this stuff to heart
because they're brainwashed by garbage
like this and next thing you know
lives are ruined that's the consequence
that woman in the video is gonna go file
a lawsuit get a whole bunch of people
fired
but on the bright side at least we're
protecting you know the ladies from
hearing the word sex at work
which will give them great comfort as
they drive home in the evening
listening to cardi b sing about her
genitals